yeah but i i feel i i completely agree
with you with like irl stream content
being
the black mirror kind of content as
opposed to any other
stream kind of content in my opinion and
i'm not sure why maybe it's because
it's you it literally is like kind of
like a slice of life where
it feels a bit too intimate i feel
especially when it's those irl streams
where it's like it's not the camera
pointing at the person but it's like
shot in pov
yeah yeah like that [ __ ] especially it's
like whoa
it's just weird it's just yeah it just
makes you think like where's it gonna go
from here
like what's the next step because
there's gonna be a next step and like
i'm just
it's only gonna one-up itself yeah yeah
which is why i'm like i wonder where
it's gonna go
like it's just it's really interesting
streaming my wife's pregnancy
kind of scary honestly i i i could see
that happening
streaming my child's birth
streaming my child's conception dad
reacts to child
birth oh it's like those [ __ ] oh
there it is
those families on youtube have like more
kids because more kids is more clickbait
pregnancies oh my god i just got
reminded of that video you found the
other day connor about the uh
the uh what's up what's in your bum
challenge right what's up what was it
yeah i mean i follow like justin wang on
twitter i don't know if you follow
justin wang
yeah yeah this man [ __ ] he loves
retweeting the most cursed [ __ ]
this man [ __ ] retweets and post the
cursed [ __ ] and
and i thought this has got to be a troll
yeah but there's literally a series on
youtube of people being like is that
is that a dildo or a dick in my house on
youtube
no joke this isn't a joke i know it's
disgusting
and like i watched it because i was like
i thought it was just me yeah i thought
this was like there was a meme
yeah there's no way this was like the
can goku
[Applause]
and then you go in and you have a look
and they're like literally he's [ __ ]
doing it and i'm like
this is on youtube what the [ __ ]
what is this and then i just like
oh yeah i think that's your dick and
it's like
what is happening
this is insane yeah
it's just like that moment of disbelief
where you just you can't quite believe
that this is this kind of content
has just we've gotten to the point where
we can post something like this on
youtube
and it's just it's not even a meme
anymore we went to [ __ ] like equals
three to this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] happened what happened who
came up with the genre it's a genre
more than one people is doing a natural
genre more than one person has done this
challenge
it's like a dead ass like youtube
challenge like pass it on
tag the next creator who was gonna do a
new what's in my bomb challenge
and before someone's like oh dude
because it's like because it was like oh
people are to be like bro just because
you're saying because it's like dudes
dude no if it was [ __ ]
women and guys doing it yeah it's not
it's [ __ ] weird
why is it on youtube i think i think
what killed me was just
how straight they were that they were
playing it yeah
there wasn't any irony no there wasn't
there was zero irony there was zero like
sarcasm and what they were doing they
were just like oh i
i think it's your dick but i don't i
don't i can't trust my butt anymore yeah
please don't watch this it is literally
what i think it's the most cursed one of
the most
personal i know we went from like you
know reaching into a box to see what it
is to just like
let's replace the box with the anus
remember when fine bros or tv shows like
is it jelly or a spider
which operation are we performing with
you is it a vasectomy
or a colonoscopy you tell me and it's
like oh okay
i think i'm being like my penis is being
surgically removed what is happening
the [ __ ] how how can youtube crack down
on dumb [ __ ] and then just leave this
[ __ ] up this is insane
i couldn't believe it
you're like oh this is fantastic this is
right like i went up to ghana's like is
it a tango or is it my mouth
i'll never tell i feel like there is a
clear line
in which would should be honestly like
when when uh
so yeah for those of you who don't know
joey did a video where we review
tenga products great video check out a
great video great video um i found it
funny because
joey didn't really tell me what we were
doing until the day of filming so
in the back of my mind i was just like
is joey just going to make me like go
behind a curtain and just like try this
[ __ ] out like well
like what am i doing today like how
[ __ ] were we going
to test it out yeah because joey was
just like yo you want to go test out
some tengas and i'm just like
yeah sure in what capacity
are we testing them out joey just boys
saying yeah just just another night with
the bros you know
cranking a cold one with the boys
yeah i just can't i can't believe that
video got made like that had to be like
filmed edited at no point in the process
people think is this too much no the
thing it wasn't just a one part series
it was multiple
it's a multiple part series and it
obviously did really well because
everyone just can't
obviously did really well because who's
not gonna [ __ ] click on that when you
see that
it's actually because it's so absurd
you're gonna be like what is this
this can't be real oh my god it's real
don't watch it
please please please do not exist do not
watch this i've never felt dirty just
looking up at youtube typing something
into my youtube search history
you know i didn't watch a little bit of
it and i did two
on youtube you're just like how are they
getting away with how it's still up is
beyond me